we've got a new statement from former
president Donald Trump Alx tweets Trump
World War III has never been closer
closer than it is right now quote take a
look at the globalist war Monger donors
backing our opponents that's because
they're candidates of War I am the
president who delivers peace and its
peace through strength I think he's
taking a swipe right there DeSantis but
I got to be honest that's probably the
most tactful swipe he could have taken
Ron Des sanctimonious and they're
they're trying to claim they call the
meatball Ron which is way better I gotta
be honest meatball Ron is better than
Ron D sanctimonious but I don't think
Trump said I think he denied it but uh
let me play a little bit of this clip
from Donald Trump for you uh not the
full thing it's four minutes but we'll
give you part of a statement here stop
the warmongers and globalists
World War III has never been closer than
it is right now we need to clean house
of all of the war mongers and America
last globalists in the Deep State the
Pentagon the state department and the
National Security industrial complex one
of the reasons I was the only president
in Generations who didn't start a war is
that I was the only president who
rejected the catastrophic advice of many
of Washington's generals bureaucrats and
the so-called diplomats who only know
how to get us into conflict but they
don't know how to get us out for decades
we've had the very same people such as
Victoria Newland and many others just
like are obsessed with pushing Ukraine
toward NATO not to mention the state
Department's support for uprisings in
Ukraine these people have been seeking
confrontation for a long time much like
the case in Iraq and other parts of the
world and now we're teetering on the
brink of World War III and a lot of
people don't see it but I see it and
I've been right about a lot of things
they all say Trump's been right about
everything none of this they all say
thank you who is they though yeah
exactly dude what's what's what's Trump
trying to say I watched this video Until
That moment and shut it off earlier as
well right after he said quote they all
say Trump's been right about everything
this hyperbolic Madness is not uh poised
for office I'm sorry the guy's not not
yeah you're wrong complete idiocy to say
that kind of thing excuse me excuse me
wrong wrong uh everyone says I'm the
greatest at everything like who the hell
talks like that Trump does Trump look
man hell no no it's a lie people that's
not a true statement he's a liar
hyperbole in lies are distinct
hyperbole can be a lie I mean Trump
being boastful and and talking like that
is kind of something I would roll my
eyes at but I gotta be real
with the East Palestine stuff
with seeing Joe Biden go to Ukraine I'm
like
um I'm I'm voting for Trump like Ron Ron
DeSantis has the tact he's got good
policy he's done great for Florida but
just like I at this was such an
unnerving
move that Joe Biden did with this
Ukraine trip it it was like getting
punched in the balls as hard as possible
and I just we need a a bloviating
bragger like Trump who really will go
down to East Palestine if that's what it
takes like I like Rhonda Santos but he's
he comes he does I don't know man I
can't explain it it's like Rhonda Santos
has done a really good job he's given us
a lot of what we want we've seen a lot
of tremendous success but he's a VP he's
he's a he's he's a commander he's
Lieutenant he's he's number one Donald
Trump is the is the crazy guy who's like
get me a plane I'm flying to East
Palestine right now and Joe Biden's the
guy who says whatever my boss tells me
to do I'll go do and then gives away our
money and then Ron DeSantis is the guy
who's like yeah we're gonna do it right
we're gonna fix it with people people
want but that's a c-o-o not a CEO
Trump's CEO Defenders a CEO for those
that understand corporate structure you
get exactly what I mean the CEO handles
the the the directives of the CEO the C
CEO which is Trump says we've got to do
this we've got to do this make it happen
it seems like and you get a DeSantis who
understands and he executes it seems
like a lesser of two evils argument I
don't really know how he's going to be
able to separate himself from the from
the lockdowns I mean but again lesser of
two evils is is something that some
people go by I've never been able to
fall into that I just
it's true
um and a lot of people have uh everybody
says you know they're all saying how
does Trump get past he was he was a
lockdown guy initially he he was the
president he wouldn't intervene in the
states decisions to keep States locked
down DeSantis did lockdown initially as
well
so I'll rub up with that I guess
you know Trump said we're going to shut
down 15 days to slow the spread DeSantis
agreed then DeSantis were first Trump as
the president didn't have the power to
force states to do anything arguably he
could invoke some you know emergency
Powers when it came to the Summer of
Love he could have you know invoked the
Insurrection act and shut down these
riots and if he did could have prevented
30 plus deaths which he should have done
but I'm just saying Man based on his
foreign policy
I I kind of I am worried As Trump points
out DeSantis does have these warmongers
these these these internationalists
these uh investment uh neocon
establishment shells getting behind him
I'm not going to blame DeSantis for that
it's what he does with the money
but I I gotta I gotta say like
with the East Palestine situation
I'm not convinced that Ron DeSantis
would be a trump in this regard
Trump is the guy who flies there and
says I'm going to visit these people
Biden's the guy who says don't know
don't care let him rot for all I care
it's surprising that every presidential
candidate isn't going there because it's
it's like a requirement you have to go
there not Nikki Haley either right Trump
was the one who announced he was going I
don't know if he did yet but still I'm
like I'll take it
that if that's what we get I my view of
trump is that there's probably a lot
better people who could be president but
I really do feel like you're more likely
to get a politician
you vote for Trump and you know what
you're getting and I think he really
does like this country I also think he's
got an ego problem do you know what
you're getting though because you know
we heard a lot of love for Wikileaks in
the run-up to you know his presidency
but then you know nothing after he got
elected so he loves Wikileaks when
they're helping him exactly you you know
Trump is going to bloviate he's going to
say things that he think will work for
his base and there's no guarantee that
happens but you do know he wants to
build a wall he's going to uh take look
Ann Coulter was complaining that he
didn't build the wall and I'm like the
dude was trying okay I really do think
Trump was trying I can respect she's mad
that we didn't get the wall and she said
you know only you know hundreds of miles
of fencing or whatever and I'm like yeah
he got triple layer Bollard fencing in
key areas it's like man I'll take what I
can get yeah it is lesser of two Evil's
argument yeah I don't I don't even know
if I feel like it it feels feel that way
like
Trump is different from the lesser of
two evils Mitt Romney and Obama was the
lesser of two evils Trump is something
outside the picture who's probably going
to do a bunch of dumb stuff
but his ego won't let him let Americans
down like here's what I think Trump's
ego is is massive probably the biggest
on the planet and you can say it's a
problem he's also very arrogant but this
means he's also desperate for the love
and admiration of the American people
and that's I'm like that right there
matters Biden doesn't give a crap at all
he knows people hate him but the media
is going to cover for him anyway so he
can abandon the American people to go
fly to Ukraine Trump on the other hand
desperately wants people to love him so
much so he puts his name everywhere to
make sure people know who he is he's got
daddy issues but you can count on that
for him to do what he can to make you
say I like you Trump and that's hey if
it's narcissism at the root but he's
desperately trying to convince you that
he's awesome I'll take it because Biden
certainly ain't doing it he's leaving
you to die I believed that about Trump
until he became president day two and
went on script and started reading off a
prompter when he was like off off book
for the whole run-up to the election
during the the process and it was like
God even got exciting I didn't even want
him to be president but it was like at
least someone's being honest and then
just I see his eyeballs tracking the
prompter as he's talking and he's
talking like this and that is not how
Donald Trump talks I'm like oh my god
well he has to come he has to come here
that's the only way that uh that you can
really press him so maybe he should
maybe I'll uh fly out for the Friday
morning show and interview Trump that'd
be cool
you should come here well the I mean
it's just not that's the other challenge
but he should be willing to because he
should want to reach these people yeah
but I'm I you know maybe if I had the
ego and arrogance of trump and don't get
me wrong like I got ego and arrogance
for sure but not enough to be like
Donald Trump should be in my studio you
know what I mean like
to feel the culture like hey he should
want to connect you know what I mean
it's not like it's not worth its time
it's like Donald Trump would be uh it
should be honored at the thought of me
letting him come here and sit in the
studio I think he needs to show up
everybody in conversation for a million
people would be well worth his time
exactly
I think that Trump didn't get everything
he said he would done and that is
disappointing some people like I
personally feel like maybe it would be
nice to get some more progress on border
security in the wall I think he did do
some things you know I can be
disappointed that it wasn't as much as
I'd like I but I think the economy was
strong under him I think that there were
a lot of positives to the Trump
presidency and kovid was a very unusual
uh way to go out that unfortunately you
know has put him in a weird position
going into 2024. I think that the
hardest thing about the Trump presidency
was that he was so good at captivating
his audience when he was campaigning and
then when he got into the White House
it's hard for me not to think that he
switched out who was around him and that
he was often misled by bad advice and I
would be afraid going at 24 if he was
elected again that he would again give
seats to advisors who maybe don't have
his best interests or the best interest
of his base at heart and that is
nerve-wracking as a voter to say like do
we do we try again it's not that we
shouldn't I mean especially given that
he is willing to go to East Palestine
when at least two Biden officials are
were at least planning like Biden did
leave the country that he had the EPA
was going to and then was like oh just
kidding I'll stay here and deal with
Ohio I mean the Biden administration's
Legacy in the past three years or
however long he's been in is not good
and I think one bad year of Trump versus
everything accomplished so you know it's
it's kind of clear who would be a
stronger candidate I'm hearing that
Trump's going to be there tomorrow I
don't know that's what I heard too uh
but he hasn't officially released a date
it's like it's like the EPA just rushed
in to beat him there can it a lot if
you're listening you want to go to Ohio
and and check this out so we'll get a
lot aliyaho see if he's interested in
going down there and that'd be really
really cool I I like DeSantis I think
he's doing really well on culture War
issues but this is the kind of stuff
that I'll I'll I'll I'll say it again
Trump is a CEO he's the Visionary he's
got the plan but he's kind of you know
the CEO is the guy in the suit who who
executes the vision of the CEO and knows
how to navigate that system to get the
job done so yeah a good CEO can do that
without a CEO you know if you have a
large company you're going to need
someone to organize but a good CEO can
do all the positions of the company
right and I think Donald Trump is a good
CEO but I don't think Ron DeSantis is I
think Rhonda Santos is a c-o-o I'm not
I'm not speaking ill of Trump's
abilities I'm saying I think DeSantis
has proven very very well that he's a
good leader but it feels to me like with
a story like this uh
you know
I I don't know Trump trump feels like
the guy after there could be a dark
horse that is completely outside the
realm that we're not thinking about for
sure no but like John Bolton no but
fully fully outside in the same way that
in the same way that Trump was an
outsider like you know who's someone
that is intellectual and has an
absolutely massive following that could
come in and stir things up well yeah
exactly he would never do it yay yeah
yay but I I mean he's smart but I don't
know if I'd call him an intellectual
like he I don't where is he what you
know if he really wants this where why
would he be about on the show for
instance that's ridiculous no no he he's
he's not wow interested apparently
Buddha judge is going he's rushing there
now I'm telling you the EPA is the
federal government is reacting to Trump
saying he was going to be there Trump
said this Friday night and they're like
oh goodness we have to beat him there
because if he goes especially to a
county he won twice in a state he won
twice and then is like I am here for you
and the Biden Ministry is not in fact
not even the bite Administration Pete
Kamala Harris anyone who might seek to
replace Biden
it's it's an unbeatable moment for Trump
and Trump mean a lot to the people who
voted him and who voted for him in the
first place Trump should show up with a
checkbook and just start writing a
thousand dollar checks to yeah and make
a viral video of it then John's like
that was my move oh no you can be like
shout out to Betty Betty Johnson did it
first but it was a tremendous idea so
we're going to do it I bet a lot of
these people were getting advice that in
the last two weeks if you go there and
there's dioxins in the air you could
very well get lymphoma some sort of skin
cancer and die like that could end your
life kind of fear I think there's a lot
of that which is even more sickening
that they has been yeah they wouldn't
have been so scared that like they would
have stayed outside the town probably
and at least even going to the general
area would have helped them so I don't
think that they were actually concerned
for their health I was for my own
personal health I actually didn't want
to go because I was like I don't want to
breathe that in there's a picture that
the Ohio EPA put up of like their the
director of the Ohio EPA the lieutenant
governor of Ohio like holding plastic
cups with water in them they're like
they're drinking the water it's fine but
I was I just kept thinking why isn't it
a video like why aren't you showing me
them actually drinking it there might be
one circulating around but they're
saying things to assuage fears by also
still not doing anything thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time